j'ai ce soit complètement différent les
banques financent tels les pollueurs à
la question et fait un peu provocante on
vous la pose en tout cas après le
dernier rapport d'oxfam et des amis de
la terre les deux ong accusent les
banques de ne pas tenir leurs
engagements et d'investir encore
beaucoup trop massivement dans le
charbon le gaz le pétrole la finance et
l l'ennemi de la planète
on écoute la vie des abeilles board il
pointe les responsabilités
en tout cas je pense que c'est très bien
qu'on ait des rapports qui font parler
et que ce soit l'occasion pour les
banques de nous répondre sur la façon
dont elles vont accompagner encore mieux
demain la transition énergétique
partager la vidéo
non je pense que c'est le métier des ong
que de ningde comment dire est que de
lancer des pétards mais là il enfin ils
feraient mieux honnêtement de lancer des
pétards là où il ya un vrai problème
les banques complice des pollueurs ça
n'a pas de sens enfin les banques elles
cherchent tellement à sécuriser
juridiquement ce qu'elles font que dans
tout leur métier
enfin que ce soit la banque
d'investissement que ce soit les
financements de projets que ce soit là
les réseaux bancaires traditionnels pour
les particuliers donnent dans tout leur
métier elle sécurise juridiquement
voilà les risques power et donc elles
ont absolument pas l'intérêt si je puis
dire à aller au travail comme on dirige
à financer des activités qui seraient
illicitement polluantes bon qu'elle
fasse dès qu'elle fasse des choix de
soutenir les activités qui effectivement
produisent
du carbone
des choses qui sont pas agréables
d'accord enfin ces activités là elles
mêmes sont dans un cadre juridique
par exemple certaines banques par
exemple ça qu'ils sont installés aux
etats-unis de ne pas refuser finalement
de travailler avec nos clients
oui contre a engagé oui mais c'est une
mode c'est l'appel au boycott c'est un
la responsabilité indirecte c'est c'est
tout ça mais franchement ça donne pour
moi là c'est vraiment un pétard mouillé
qui n'a aucun sens donc fort du point
richard brooks est compatible alors avec
le capitalisme cette affaire non ça nous
arrive d'être d'accord mais sur ce sujet
non enfin d'abord il ya une première
chose à dire c'est que les banques
aujourd'hui communique beaucoup sur le
fait qu'elle change et dans les faits
c'est un peu plus de l'emploi dit c'est
que c'est un peu plus lent à mettre en
place parce que j'y reviendrai il n'y a
pas non plus que des complices des pôles
heures il ya aussi des banques qui
cherchent à sortir de leur stratégie
précédente et à s'organiser pour -
financer le crédit agricole la fai ne
financera plus en 2025
toutes les activités qui sont liées au
charbon donc on a des banquiers s'est
mêlé il faut y aller dans l'alliance
colocks d'indications ce qu'il faut dire
par contre c'est que les banques n'ont
pas été très j'allais dire très très
avenante quand on leur a proposé de
s'engager et que les assurances l'ont
fait avant et que les banques sont un
peu les dernières à rentrer dans le jeu
de comment les acteurs réunis autour de
la table de la coop 21 peuvent à
recommander à leurs niveaux participer
c'est un peu les dernières les villes
l'ont fait largement avant l'assurance a
fait avant les banques viennent que
maintenant 20 donc il y a encore dans ce
que les banques financent peut
effectivement des stratégies qui sont un
petit peu étonnante et qui sont
effectivement des projets de pollueurs
ou d'organismes impôts leur faut le dire
le rapport a raison de le pointer là où
le rapport peut-être ne va pas assez
loin c'est de montrer les stratégies
mises en place que soit le bonus malus
avec certains que ce soit donc les
sorties sur les financements charbon
pour d'autres bref il ya des efforts qui
sont faits et simplement ça n'a pas très
vite et on a connu les banques pouvant
aller plus vite
le monde est certes réelle mais dans le
monde réel on peut faire aussi des choix
les banques ou encore cette capacité
elle était réuni il ya pas très
longtemps à new york l on fait des
rempl en comme aujourd'hui ce qu'on leur
demande c'est comment elle les mettre
réellement en place et peut-être en
allant un peu plus vite parce que la
lutte contre le climat nous offre le
règlement climatique par non nous oblige
à aller plus vite aujourd'hui c'est à la
fois une question d' accélération de
leur modèle est une question plutôt de
valoriser ce qu'elles ont mis en place
franck c'est des bonnes stratégies c'est
ça qu'on aurait dû voir aussi dans le
rapport
le pardon que les forces de rappel
business sont tellement fortes que c'est
pas enfin que ce discours n'est pas
réaliste pourra pas d'un méfieront
rappaz daïra on va pas dire ah là là je
ne sais pas moi au crédit lyonnais de ne
pas financer le besoin en fonds de
roulement comtal comment est ce que
c'est parce que c'est lorsque c'est une
maj je pense que dans ce cas là il faut
parler des bons exemples des bonnes
pratiques comment le crédit agricole y
arrive pourquoi aujourd'hui la société
générale ne fait pas les mêmes efforts
sur aucun début des polanco vous sentiez
sont font toutes les deux cités par
oxfam en contre exemple en état de
tuvalu kaki dont le mais vous me citer
en exemple une banque qui malgré toi du
tournoi maintenant en 2018 le rapport
d'oxfam cité d'ailleurs en exemple le
crédit agricole sur sa stratégie charbon
ce que vous évoquez
et vous avez raison c'est que une banque
comme le crédit agricole s'est pas sur
toutes les énergies fossiles où il est
bon il est bon elle est bonne pardon sur
la partie qui concerne le charbon elle
n'est pas bonne sur le pétrole et elle
n'est pas bonne sur le gaz est là elle
doit faire des efforts si vous prenez
vous semblez paribas celle inverse bnp
paribas fait pas d'efforts sur le
charbon et elle est notamment montré du
doigt parce qu'elle soutient le charbon
et les usines à charbon en allemagne qui
sont un des principaux pollueurs en
revanche elle fait des efforts sur le
gaz est là notamment pas
d'investissements sur le gaz de schiste
et c'est une avancée ce que je dis c'est
que ces pratiques là qu'il faut mettre
en oeuvre et oui on peut le faire il n'y
a pas d'impossibilité puisque ce sont
les banquettes sont les acteurs qui font
le bonus malus est pas moins l'une est
vite qu'il ya les bonnes pratiques
marque est ce que finalement le prêt
d'une banque c'est de faire du profit ou
l'écologie c'est de faire du profit
le profit après moral et business ça
jamais fait bon ménage
un actif un peu plus morale que d'autres
donc ça dépend des des velléités de
chacune c'est un terme qui doit
s'immiscer dans les affaires ça peut en
tout cas il n'y a pas de raison et vous
avez vous à voir
effectivement on peut tout à fait
décider qu'une banque ne va pas financer
des énergies polluantes même titre
qu'elle va pas financer les énergies de
l'armement ou là le tabac ou l'alcool
tout peut-être que ça provoque la mort
voilà je veux dire c'est celle à
mouiller la morale c'est des choix
politiques
c'est aussi des choix politiques là en
l'occurrence le problème d'oxfam ce
qu'ils font pas dans la nuance
je veux dire oxfam c'est de la com
politique cécile duflot à la bon jeu de
critiquer la com politique da comme des
banques a fait de la com politique aussi
jeudi il ya c'est pas dans la nuance est
binaire cia pas il n'y a même pas de
gentils ya que des méchants et et elle
voit et le rock slam présente le monde
tel qu'il devrait être
c'est formidable moi j'aimerais vivre
dans le pays de candy électronique du
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil
sauf que c'est le monde réel c'est pas
celui là et les banques elles
travaillent pas dans un monde imaginaire
c'est pas les bisounours et et je sais
pas qui c'est le monde réel avec
aujourd'hui des avions qui polluent il
faut bien permettre richard quand vous
allez en déplacement à l'étranger pour
vos week end eh ben il faut bien vous
financez vous prenez l'avion en tant que
j'ai me rappeler que je pourrais y aller
et on pourrait pour essayer des banques
pourrait également ne plus financer
renault souhaitais que des voitures
roulent encore en laissant c'est que le
le passage à l'hybride ou à l'électrique
ne va pas assez vite sauf qu'on vit dans
le monde réel et que les gens on l'a
bien vu que les gilets jaunes ont pas
les moyens de s'acheter des voitures
électriques et les voitures hybrides la
douleur à des grèves dans les environs
et que j'ai enlevé le web mais on est
d'accord qui a des bonnes pratiques qui
viendrait le valorise à tiques oui mais
ça oxfam et vous l'avez vu m'ont dit tu
ne le fais par bertrand dernier oui
aurait été tout cela se résume à une
question c'est est ce que les banques
doivent financer l'économie ou orienter
l'économie
aujourd'hui elles financent l'économie
telle qu'elle est et tu nous dire et on
si elle refusait mais tentant star en
péril des pompiers de l'économie
l'économie bah oui elle repose aussi sur
les énergies fossiles c'est pas bien
mais est-ce que les banques doivent
aussi avoir un rôle d'aiguillon d'un
changement de modèle économique
oui probablement c'est en train de
changer pour une raison très simple et
vous le disiez une banque ça gère quoi
ça gère des risques et elle ne finance
pas ce qui est trop risqué il y a 20 ans
30 ans 40 ans la finance verte c'était
trop risqué aujourd'hui c'est moins
risqué et c'est même obligatoire et donc
naturellement parce que c'est de moins
en moins risqué de financer les
activités écologiques et que ces mêmes
de plus en plus rentable bien
naturellement le mouvement ce faire il
faut savoir si on raisonne en stock ou
en flux en stock effectivement il ya un
an grosso modo 70% des investissements
des banques qui vont vers des énergies
qui sont des énergies fossiles et puis
bah en flux évidemment il ya un
rattrapage qui va se faire comme à
l'échelle de l'économie parce que en
effet pas que financé on fait aussi une
orientation d'économies et la banque a
aussi un côté avant garde pour indiquer
ce qu'on va financer demain dans un
cadre politique a su comment est-ce que
le gouvernement doit être plus
contraignant c'est ce que réclame est
l'objet m en tout cas il ya une chose
qui est con qu'on aurait pu avoir en
parallèle c'est ce que font les banques
pour financer autre chose que les
énergies fossiles
qu'est ce qu'elles font pour financer
des projets des initiatives qui sont
notamment le falloir alors je vous
répète pourquoi je dis ça parce que vous
rappelez peut-être du rapport d'oxfam de
2018 qui disait que justement il y avait
un désengagement en 2018 donc sur les
chiffres probablement 2017 des banques
sur les énergies renouvelables et l'idée
était bon on en est aujourd'hui et sur
cette partie là ce qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup communiquer c'est encore
dommage parce que là encore on a
peut-être une pratique intéressante des
banques qui est de dire je descends et
joe décroît et mais à côté je finance
davantage les énergies noir ce qui
serait content dan un changement de
modèle
on fait dans le temps mais risque malgré
tout tous les indicateurs sont pas bidon
c'est un peu ce qu'a dit bill gate dans
le times récemment où il a dit
finalement dans cette matière là dans la
finance verte on n'a pas d'indicateur
sinon je pense que les indicateurs ont
leur intérêt n'est vraiment les banques
ont financé l'éolien le photovoltaïque
on peut pas considérer qu'elles ont
complètement ignoré ces bandes
d'économie tous ces fonds soit disant
verts qui ont des labels le plus ou
moins sérieuses est ce que finalement
tout ça tient à des emprunts toxiques
s'était pas non plus très labellisé
enfin c'était pas cher que des idées que
moi se rappelle encore voilà donc en
gros bombe puis prenez on parler de
morale et business en france alors là on
parle d'énergie fossile mais en france
on belle nucléaire est ce que les
banques doivent de continuer à
développer
ap ap michael est le terme ces
responsables du oui mes responsabilités
est ce que la responsable d'une banque
c'est de continuer à financer un projet
comme le père de flamanville par exemple
quand on est à 12 milliards de
développement alors qu'il devait coûter
quatre fois moins cher au départ
est-ce que là c'est de la responsabilité
est ce que le contribuable français est
content de savoir que in fine et c'est
lui qui va payer
la question se pose aussi quelque part
est ce que les ong s imaginent une
seconde que d edf est de couper de ses
moyens de financement parce que les
banques se mettrait à devenir moral
entre guillemets parce qu'à vos produits
si le niveau est sérieusement menacée la
décroissance au cas où si la crédibilité
de l'omg en question ont ouvert un bobo
de problème voilà
mais il ya aussi un impact qui est
moindre à un nombre humide wings h f
vous vous le pensez mais d'autres ont
considéré que le nucléaire c'est tout
aussi dommageable pour d'autres raisons
pour une grue les énergies fossiles a
pour une banque elle pourrait s'appuyer
sur des données qui disent que en gros
le nucléaire est moins impactants pour
le climat et le dérèglement climatique
que ne le sont les énergies fossiles et
elle aurait raison elle privilégierait
l'une à l'autre qu'on pourrait
difficilement sauf que là empoché sauf
vous allez me dire si londres la
communication politique mais en
l'occurrence parce que je pense c'est
qu'elles n'ont ce rapport ne pond des
repas les efforts des bas des banques et
ne le met pas en exergue c'est un
changement de modèle aussi pour les
banques d édition du tardivement il faut
le dire mais aujourd'hui elles le font
peut-être pas assez pour l'énergie aie
sur la violation de l'être par exemple
pour le nucléaire
quelqu'un pourrait vous dire mais c'est
beaucoup plus docile à long terme parce
que les déchets radioactifs au vous
aider les garder pendant des centaines
de milliers d'années alors que l'énergie
fossile j'irai naturel par principe
c'est pragmatisme et les banques et rond
sur le verre quand ça leur rapportera
élan soyons sérieux on voit encore
dépendre du pétrole pendant cinquante
ans on ne va pas cesser de filtrer et du
nucléaire il ya d'autres questions qui
peuvent se poser sur nucléaire admire 4
le seul souci des banques c'est
maximiser toujours et encore toujours
les profits c'est pas tout à fait ce que
vous nous dites richard oui mais c'est
pas fou
simplement je sais que c'est mal non
mais ce que je mets en sus que je met en
exergue ses dents dans la aujourd'hui
c'est le fait que les banques doivent
être amenés à changer changer de modèle
sur lequel elles se sont aussi
construite et que l'on pourra faire des
profits autrement peut-être - et
peut-être d'une manière qui soit
compatible avec un enjeu qui ô croix est
commun à tous et on dit aujourd'hui tout
ce qui est autour de l'économie et de la
finance doit contribuer à la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
et c'est les acteurs eux mêmes qui le
disent puisqu'il se réduit c'est qu'il
communique dessus donc ce qu'il faut
c'est les inciter à aller vers les actes
des paroles qu'ils ont prononcés et
peut-être accéléré comme on invite
d'ailleurs tout le monde s'est avéré les
états les villes les lisation tout le
monde doit accélérer parce que l'enjeu
est devant nous donc ballet dansé sur la
chine les etats unis qui ne respecte
absolument aucun des infos qu'ils ont
signé ah ben on est belle soit la
stratégie d'oxfam à ces offensives et
peut-être jusqu'au boutiste et la bonne
dans cette idée d'accélération nous
c'est la politique énergie ong mais une
politique énergétique c'est une
politique donc ça doit être des styles
ça doit être décidé par
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
etc ça n'est pas un jeu de lobby bon et
la fluence et par des lobbys oui bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr mais enfin dont
oxfam est en principe mais en principe
la politique énergétique de long terme
de la france doit être définie par à
part les mains à travers leurs
représentants
merci on parle d'abord et le monde
je veux vous remercier notre troisième
sujet ce soir la justice française est
elle suffisamment indépendante c'est une
information de notre journaliste paul
gonzalez la cour de justice pourrait
bientôt privé la france du droit de
délivrer un mandat d'arrêt européen car
elles estiment selon son avocat général
en tout cas que les garanties
d'indépendance des procureurs ne sont
pas suffisantes alors en 2013 vous
rappeler que les instructions
individuelles orale garde des sceaux ont
été supprimés mais la cour européenne
conteste également les instructions
générales
on écoute nicole belloubet qui était
interrogé sur l'indépendance du